cette 12h20 alors tu es prête je t'aime
maman
allez les filles ont créé
non
vic et sentir envoie-t-on faire
qui sans quoi pas grand chose le
champignon et puis là aussi une ode au
règne mal qu'il a mangé ferme les yeux
inquiets qu'ils sont là pis on est aussi
un peu le café
[Musique]
je tape tout ça où tu as lanceur pour
tout seul pourquoi je la connaissais pas
avant alors je veux qu'elle s'en aille
je supporte pas
elle est chez vous mamie
pas ça quand même et c'est une [ __ ]
folle furieuse qui tu vois des choses
j'aurai une petite fille
il devra en fait dans ma chambre de
julien et cambo quick je viens de
retrouver dans le jardin c'est pas toi
non plus je sais ce que tu fais tu as
tout avant que ça dégénère au clair
[Musique]
pourquoi tu es revenue m'ont vraiment
été bon
on
[Musique]